amazing when I look at George and see
that he is 81 years old I am amazed
every time I mean this guy looks like
he's 35 years younger than it does take
care of yourself and imminently quickly
what we need to do we need to eat
properly we need to exercise you're
still walking a lot walking a lot a in
the fitness center every morning
really hey and keep the mind still doing
a hundred push-ups yes a hundred
push-ups push-ups and 50 sit-ups every
day every day at 81 at 81 look at you
you have any belly oh yeah you know
that's the thing that comes with age my
stomach is popping out I mean really I
went to my doctor and said isn't there
something I can eat or not eat to get
this down limit down a little yeah I'm
just still doing my situps and isn't it
interesting that you still care I think
that's what keeps you young and
vivacious you are 81 and looking much
younger because you care that your
stomach is getting but we want to be
enjoying life right yeah yeah some
people are always saying they're tired
you know yes well Howard is one always
time oh you're all right right now yeah
I wouldn't believe it I mean you're so I
feel I've hired well I don't know what
it is
wake well maybe it's contagious who
knows who knows I should visit you more
often